journalists
distinguished ministers
Institute foreign
on its promises
[Music]
The First Agreement
foreign
other European languages the European
Union
this document
says
foreign
and this is
except foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
Europe
an better services
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
category foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
ladies and gentlemen it's so great to be
back here in Scorpio
and indeed I vividly remember my last
visit four months ago when I came to
address the parliament of North
Macedonia here
and I also very clearly remembered that
at that day as you can imagine what we
have promised
and yes we have promised that if North
Macedonia the parliament is able to take
the necessary steps it would lead to the
opening of accession negotiations
it would then start the screening
process of the EUR key without any delay
and above all that we would fully
respect your identity and your language
that is the Macedonian language
and I must say the adimita it took a lot
of leadership that you have shown and a
lot of courage to your Parliament from
North Macedonia to cross that threshold
and I'm so glad that you did
because it led to that historic day of
July when we finally opened accession
negotiations
and dear prime minister as I promised
the screening of the aqui started
immediately
and it is now firmly on track and the
negotiation process is gaining momentum
and there's very good work being done
and finally indeed on your language I
promise to you that we would get the
frontex agreement signed translate it
into the Macedonian language no footnote
no asterisks on equal footing with all
the 24 languages of the European Union
and today we delivered we deliver it and
as I said 20 they are 24 official
languages in the European Union I am
deeply convinced it will not take too
long then we will have 25 because the
Macedonian language is such a beautiful
language
and I really want to thank the
commissioner Johansson for her childless
work on the agreement
and this agreement is not only very
important because it strengthens our
cooperation on migration
but also because it shows that there can
be no doubt that the Macedonian language
is your language and we fully respect
that
now North Macedonia is moving forward
along the European path
and that is what our latest enlargement
report also shows we have just published
this enlargement report and I must
really congratulate you this is amazing
to see how determined you're moving
forward you have strengthen strengthened
your democracy you have strengthened
your rule of law you've made progress in
the reform of your justice system
you are developing a solid market
economy that has already proven its
resilience so congratulations on the
progress on the success so far and I
know that you are and listening to you I
am deeply convinced that you are
determined to keep up the good speed the
good Pace to move on on the path towards
the European Union
and I am very aware that you are doing
all this against a very challenging
backdrop and that is Russia's brutal war
against our friends and Neighbors in
Ukraine
this war is bringing cruelty and
destruction to the Ukrainian people
and is is sending shock waves through
the entire world
as we all know and see Russia is using
energy for example as a weapon and it is
heavily manipulating the energy Market
this results in Rising Energy prices and
in problems in security of supply
and yes North Macedonia has been
affected too
but rest assured we are feeling the same
pressure but we will not give in not a
single centimeter rest assured that um
what we show in the European Union
solidarity and unity also means
solidarity and unity with North
Macedonia because we are in this
together and this means that we will
solve this crisis and we will overcome
this crisis together we will keep
supporting our friends in Ukraine and we
will be very strong and determined to
make sure that he and the European Union
there is the solidarity and the unity
that we need my message today to the
citizens of North Macedonia is very
clear the European Union is by your side
we are in this together and we will go
through this together and we will
overcome this crisis together and move
towards a better future
we are putting forward now an energy
package a support package for the whole
Western Balkan it begins with grants 80
million grants here for North Macedonia
as immediate budget support
it will help address the impact of the
high energy prices on your citizens and
on your businesses
and we will finalize this by the end of
the year so that you can get the funding
already in January
but of course more will come for example
there are 500 million grants for the
whole region to invest in what is so
necessary now to get our independence to
invest in energy connections to invest
in Energy Efficiency and of course to
invest in renewable energy we have
spoken about it that we need to be
self-sufficient with energy so for
example the renewable energy that is
homegrown that creates good jobs here
and that makes us independent of Russian
fossil fuels
this support and more financial support
will be channeled under the so-called
economic and investment plan
as you know the investment plan is
already at work
with investments in Wind parks for
example in solar power
plants I was very happy to see to hear
that you are planning to intensify this
work and with new gas interconnection
between your country and Serbia and
Kosovo that are planned also
so finally it will also enable you to
participate in the European joint
procurement for pipeline gas and LNG we
have decided in the European Council
that we want to purchase to buy gas on
the global market together because this
strengthened strengthens our purchasing
power we invite you North Macedonia to
join us to be with us so that we go to
the market together and of course all
the decisions we have taken in the last
days the legal proposals that we have
taken to reduce the prices of gas in the
European Union but more importantly the
prices of electricity you are benefiting
of course from that too because we are
in one energy Union and this means
whatever we do we do it together as I
said unity and solidarity
it was touching to listen to you it was
moving the people of North Macedonia and
you and your government and many many
many people in this country have shown
so much commitment to European Union
values
and therefore I am deeply convinced
indeed that you will move forward on
your path to membership you deserve to
move forward on the path to membership
it was touching for me to listen to you
what you said about young people in
North Macedonia and yes they are
dreaming of Europe but I am also deeply
convinced they are dreaming of North
Macedonia in the European Union a place
where they want to shape the future of
North Macedonia you can rely on us and
we know that we can rely on you
I know that you still have a way ahead
of you but you are able the way I got to
know you and the determination that I've
seen and this Parliament I've spoken to
the people of Macedonia that I have met
I am deeply convinced that you are able
to make the dream of your young people
come true in North Macedonia because let
me tell you I'm deeply convinced that
Europe the European Union is not
complete without North Macedonia we want
to have you with us we are friends we
are partners and one day we're going to
be in one European Union thank you very
much
Tamara
um
you did not mention the Constitutional
Amendments
on your part they will not vote in favor
of the Constitutional Amendments
yes of course we have in our bilateral
spoken about this very important topic
of the Constitutional Amendment and you
know I am deeply convinced that the
north macedonians finally will come
together will form a majority that makes
it possible to vote positively to the
Constitutional Amendment you have
managed so much you have gone through so
much you have been so successful in the
way forward that I'm deeply convinced
that here in the country in North
Macedonia you will find the convincing
arguments to finally understand that it
is everyone's responsibility to
participate or to contribute that this
country is moving forward I was speaking
of the young people who have a dream and
I call on all politicians to make this
dream of the young people a reality
Russian
question
uh
[Music]
question two prime minister kovachovski
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
your language because you just respect
ours so uh Madam President we all know
that the the biggest problem of our
society's crime and Corruption how this
process should change the the mentality
of our uh Balkan officials to change the
mentality of Balkan politicians to take
action and to make a real change when
it's needed and not just to adapt laws
because our prime minister knows exactly
what I'm talking about
so the accession process and the
negotiations in the accession process
has very clear steps on the rule of law
the independence of the Judiciary the
fight against corruption and any country
that ever joined the European Union
underwent these processes did the
reforms
so these will be the reforms for every
country that is in the accession process
for the European Union
and this is a constant process to uphold
the rule of law not only in the with the
con for the countries that want to join
the European Union but also within the
European Union we have a rule of law
report for example once a year within
the European Union to over and over and
over strengthen the institutions that
are providing the rule of law or that
are fighting for example organized crime
or that are fighting the corruption so
North Macedonia like other countries
will undergo these reforms will be
stronger you have done a lot already
you've been working intensely
intensively on that topic I recommend
the report the enlargement report that
that was that was just published but of
course there's still a way to go
for both prime minister and the
president
speaking in the context of the frontex
agreement do you expect a new wave of
migras on the Southeastern flank of the
EU from the crisis region including
Ukraine thank you including great
so I
we are in a very serious
situation
and we see the
atrocious brutality and cruelty with
which Russia is attacking civil
infrastructure
with the clear aim in Ukraine to cut off
men women children of heating of water
of electricity with the winter coming
and we see these vicious attacks on for
example housing
and civil infrastructure like
kindergarten hospitals schools you name
it
and we are aware of the fact that Russia
tries everything not only to terrorize
the Ukrainian people and to paralyze
that country but also to push people out
of the Ukrainian people out of Ukraine
so there's a two-fold approach first of
all there's a strong support from all of
us
what military equipment is concerned for
Ukraine to defend itself and to protect
its citizens
second as much as possible we help
immediately with to repair the
infrastructure to care for shelter for
example to make sure that the people who
lost everything the internally displaced
people have for the winter the support
that is that is necessary but yes we are
also ready and preparing in case that
even more refugees from Ukraine are
coming
I must say I'm deeply touched by the
experience how citizens opened their
hearts and their homes to Ukrainian
refugees
in the course of this atrocious War
than 8 million people have come to the
European Union many have gone back I
must also say to Ukraine to help bring
that country forward but at the moment
being we have for a round about 4
million ukrainians that are asking for
temporary protection which is granted to
them
and therefore it is an enormous enormous
challenge but also an enormous
show of friendship and solidarity of the
people of this country of other
countries in the European Union in
Europe itself
to give all the support that is possible
and necessary for the Ukrainian refugees
my message is very clear whatever
atrocious tactic
Putin is trying we will stand together
and we will not let it happen that our
friends in Ukraine will be put under
even more pressure we will stand
together with solidarity and we will
make sure that Ukraine will prevail
foreign
Ty the country it is an attack over
innocence
whatever we can do considering our
capacities to assist the Ukrainian
citizens
doing so and we will continue
Bruno our country
just from Ukraine they're here
migration waves from Aziz
I believe that our ministry of foreign
foreign
thank you for your attention
foreign
[Music]